this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house greetings from podcast bill it's
Monday the 15th of May the joint is
brought to you by bluetooth listen let's
talk about sex baby boys remember we
used to be able to go all night like a
Savage maybe that's more difficult than
it used to be now you're getting old
you're tired but get your hands on some
Bluetooth it's Ed medicine that ship
straight through your door it's got the
same ingredients as Viagra Cialis and
Levitra but they're chewable tablets at
a fraction of the cost I love blue shoe
comes in a little pouch you just pop one
pill drink a little water baboon and
it's easy and entirely online no trip to
the doctor no awkward conversations and
everything is shipped in a discrete
package just sign up at bluetooth.com
and meet with one of our licensed
medical providers and once you get
approved you'll get the prescription
within days Bluetooth wants to help you
have better sex the summer's coming baby
Let It All Hang Out discover the options
at
bluetooth.com chew it do it and I I
can't tell the other thing to do but
anyway plus your Uncle Joey has a
special deal for the for the joint
family you ready try Bluetooth for free
when you get promo code Joey you're like
I'm getting the heart on for free [__]
yeah Uncle Joe is coming at you direct
on a Monday just pushing Joey at
checkout and pay five dollars for
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
Joey to receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for details the
joint is also brought to you by
DraftKings it's going down the NF NBA
season is getting hotter you got some
great teams in there you got the Lakers
you got Denver you got Miami you got oh
my God it's tremendous and DraftKings
Sportsbook is there for you new
customers make a five dollar bet and
score a buck 50 and bonus bets instantly
Plus everyone can score wait here it is
no sweat same game parlay every single
day during the NBA playoffs who takes
care of you like DraftKings nobody and
if your bet losers you still got a Bonus
bet back and an amount of your initial
bet up to ten dollars you got nothing to
lose and everything to win download the
DraftKings sports book app and sign up
with code Joey new customers can make a
five dollar bet and score 150 in bonus
bets instantly only at DraftKings
Sportsbook called Joey if you got a
gambling problem call 1-800 Gambler if
not let's get this [__] party started
it's Monday light your nut sack on fire
Uncle Joe is coming at you direct
welcome to Uncle Joey's Joy
[Music]
foreign
what's happening you bad [__]
Uncle Joey here was a great week I'm
looking forward to this week
thank you I had a good time on uh your
garbage last week and also on Boston
Sports the Irish Brothers are [__]
tremendous you know it was funny when I
walked in there I didn't even know they
had the studio turned on
yeah that's what they're saying I just
yeah I just sat down and started
bullshitting with them and started
yelling and screaming and next thing you
know I'm like yeah I didn't [__] know
the next thing you know I gotta pee and
he's like and then we're gonna start he
goes we started this [__]
already so if I offend anybody anything
I don't know when I walked in there I
was stoned as [__] hell I just landed
in New York City with the ferry like one
of those pilgrims and I went over to the
side the Uber was taking too [__]
late and I went over to the side and I
burnt one of these [__] tremendous
[__] joints with the [__] lava in
it and my [__] eyebrow was almost on
fire was tremendous I got my little taxi
cab and I walked into that [__]
Barstool Sports an amazing Place great
Network great people
uh thank you everybody
the book is uh doing great because of
you guys thank you for spreading the
word and thank you for having my back I
also popped my head up on Law and Order
last week it wasn't the role you guys
wanted to see me and but hey sometimes a
life mimics art you know what I'm saying
or sometimes art mimics life I was a
[__] Baker
that's what I went to prison for
remember when I went to prison I became
a baker this time I didn't even blow up
the [__] cannolis listen it was
people people gave me [__] like they
were like Joey you were in and out it
was a little scene do you think
I give a [__] you know like people like
why did you take that role it was so
small it's like guys
there's no role that's too small oh
there's no small roads there's only
small actors somebody told me that one
time when I booked the scene with one
[__] line I wanted that turned it
into five so you never know but it uh
listen man I like action you know you
can only sit here so [__] much I knew
there was going to be a [__] Rider
strike if you guys don't know what's
going on that's just a rider strike with
the writer's Guild of America they're
striking over you know
streaming which has been a [__]
problem since it got out a few people
don't know listen it's not just can you
imagine you work all your life you
create a show you get the show made
and you get no answers it's like I tell
people all the time and I hope yeah and
I hope you're not mad at me a lot of
people like hey when is the book signing
I have no [__] idea they don't tell
you nothing hey what is your episode of
Law and Order coming out I don't [__]
know they don't tell you nothing I
didn't know the episode came out until
it was after it was on people my
sister-in-law hit me up to say I just
saw you on loan on and I go really they
already played that [__] episode
yeah I thought it was coming out in
three or four [__] weeks so
that's you know they don't tell you
nothing guys how many times do I have to
tell you you think that's they're nice
people and they tell you all the movies
coming out here and they don't tell you
nothing that's why I don't ask
when I go on a set that's why I don't
ask I don't say a dick I worry about
what I'm doing everybody's worried about
when it's coming out I'm worried about
the job and why I'm [__] mad that's
the problem
that's the [__] problem I don't ask
stupid [__] questions it's like when
I was writing the book do you know what
the cover is going to be do you know
what your [__] is going to look like
when you're 60. not really so what do
you bothering me for about the cover we
haven't even started writing the [__]
book and they already wanted a [__]
cover
so everybody always puts the [__]
whatever the the horse before the egg I
don't know what the expression is I
don't [__] know but it's like uh what
the [__] guys nobody tells you [__]
okay nobody tells you [__] I'm doing
some TV thing to promote the book I'll
tell you when it comes closer but guess
who got it for me you think the
publicity guy got it for me no Dino from
Uncle Vinnie's got it for me got me
something that they've been well we've
been calling back and forth Dino made
one call and there I am on the 24th
showing up so guys please you have no
idea about this [__] world it's like
I have a friend of mine that tortures me
constantly about I need a headshot for a
friend of my [__] there's no more
headshots well how come everybody else
hasn't had shots and I have to explain
to him that this world became digital
so the the biggest [__] failure I
ever saw in my life guys was the
photography business in L.A you guys got
to remember when I got to LA
you went to a photographer he charged
you 200 bucks
for four reels of shooting 36 in a reel
I think I don't know don't quote me on
this
then you pay him a deuce okay let me
tell you how long for you [__]
are like oh my God I can't wait to get
headshots get ready for this and that
tough if you're an [__] can you
imagine if you're a [__] sheep
because this is the process you have to
take the picture then he calls you and
he gives you a contact sheet with all
your [__] sheets now if you're a
sheep you take that and take it to your
manager and your agent and they look at
it with a lens with you
and then you pick a headshot with them
and they'll confuse you even more than
when you're confused
they'll just tell you we don't like this
one how come you didn't have a shovel in
this one how come you weren't by the bar
and you're like shut the [__] up you
weren't [__] there and then after
that's all said and done you have to
circle the shots send them back to the
photographer then he blows it up to you
one size that's his job he charges a 20
a piece so between the agent and the
manager the agent likes three the other
guy wants two and the other jerk off one
street a commercial agent so right there
that's what that's [__] 140 and
[__] headshots in the photographer
and then after you get those seven
headshots
you got to make 300 copies of each for
99 dollars
okay yourself nobody gives you a dime
these guys that go out there like I'm a
yeah this is why and then after you get
that headshot you got to pay Actors
Access sixty dollars to put your
headshot on so you can get auditions you
got to pay commercial agents another
hundred and something just to put your
picture on there so Asians could see it
and there is the evolution of a [__]
headshot so before you even get an
acting role you should be down 600 800
bucks if you're a [__] [__] Uncle
Joey did it my way I got some guy to
take a picture of me for [__] the bar
from The Comedy Store The Piano guy at
the time not the guy who died got past
his soul God Rest his soul but some
other Spanish guy that was out there on
off nights I had him he's like I do
headshots for like 25 bucks done he took
a picture of me it's still in the
hallway at The Comedy Store with the
glasses yeah that's the worst headshot
in the world but guess what I took it he
made me a copy no 20 bucks I didn't take
it to my agent to get that [__]
opinion
didn't need that [__] opinion because
they what do they know
what do they know
so from there I took it to the head shop
place and I got
I used to go to a different one with a
Chinese guy he was tremendous there was
a guy an old guy that had a Chinese
girlfriend he died a fat guy but then
there was a guy in the corner behind
hoi's walk and that [__] was my
buddy and he would make me a hundred
head shots 100 business cards
for 99 I still got that well I I they
evolved I don't have any more with the
[__] glasses on his [__] but
so I started going to him and that went
on for like five or six years and then
about 15 years ago because because this
is the science the science is this
they're sending you out on auditions so
every month what you do is every three
weeks
I would go to the agent's office and
stock the headshots myself
so they would remember who I am and they
would see me and see how I change over
the month these are strategies that
nobody does guys just your Uncle Joey
back in the day you go I would go to my
commercial agent once every three weeks
and I would go to my theatrical agent
and before you bring them shots you have
to go to Charlie Chan Printing and make
a hundred resumes cut them to eight by
ten by yourself and then staple them to
the back of the [__] headshot so
don't tell me we don't [__] work
[__] and you do this all yourself
because if you're stapling headshots you
got no assistance I never had no [__]
assistant and then you got to buy the
yellow envelopes and guess what you got
to put your [__] your Reeboks on or
whatever the [__] you're wearing and get
the walking because you got to go drop
those off in mailboxes but then they
stop using headshots
the last I'll never forget about seven
years ago I was talking to some girl and
she goes my mother I like to do the
headshots first of all I'm not a good
looking dude
but sometimes if you take 50 pictures of
me there's always going to be one that
you're going to go Joey it looks okay
and I'm okay with that
dog I paid this lady 400 bucks
and there wasn't one good picture of me
and then my buddy came over I paid him
50 and I got like 10 pictures of him
because he knew how to shoot me you know
we just take good pictures of me I'll
tell you the best photographers for Joey
Diaz Felicia Michaels
Felicia Michaels would take pictures of
me that I would go what the [__] and
Troy Conrad that's why he made the cover
a [__] tremendous Troy Conrad but the
picture business is gone
and people constantly ask you for a
[__] headshot and they think I'm
lying to them
the headshot business is gone you know
photography listen when I was growing up
you could still see him in Jersey
you'll go to a [__] little mall or
something like that or was it all the
Mills
no the little [__] uh the little
photography Huts in it yeah those little
Kia in fact I went to a mall today and I
saw and I go wow it's a jewelry fixed
thing you know they fixed jewelry there
like you drop it off on Saturday and
pick it up on Saturday yeah the
photography business kind of [__]
because it all became digital
so when people ask me for a headshot I'm
like guys
I don't have no [__] headshots I've
looked I've got maybe like one of the
old school ones that uh
Joshua's brother
made for me years ago
and I have another one
that I have to save I just got one of
each you know yeah I got printed I'm not
gonna give that out for [__] listen
for my daughter or whatever the [__] you
know
and that's all I got it's [__] crazy
you you would go into my house
and there would be
three boxes
of 300 headshots in each 900 pictures
so it was uh it's really [__] weird
how people think that there's a headshot
business there ain't [__] [__]
speaking of headshots
sometimes you got to be careful where
you put your head shot you know I went
to do Barstool Sports Tuesday
it was an 11 o'clock uh thing I got out
of there like 12 30. and I'm like [__]
this is perfect because I get to go back
to Eden City and get my little steaks on
a stick you know me dog I'm a I'm a
[__] old habits die hard I don't
wanna
yeah it was so [__] good for 350 a
piece they're so [__] delicious these
little steaks on the stick
I'm like I definitely gotta [__] get
one of these so
I cut through the I went to the ferry
[__] when I got on the ferry in North
Burton Weehawken to go to the city I got
on the elevator after I parked and the
girl came up to me she's like you went
to school with my mom
and I go really what's your mom's name
and she dropped it I'm like [__] I
didn't just go to school with your mom I
used to [__] drink with your mom you
know we all got in those little kid
circles you know so I got to talk to her
on the way over and then on the way back
there was nobody on the ferry and I
[__]
stopped in the city there was some
[__] uh homeless lady causing a big
[__] problem
we stunk like garlic had died 10 times
like she really did I caught up with her
but I you know I still remember being in
the third grade and [__] uh sister
and a banana not the one I attacked
sister Hannah was a very nice nun
she told me one time that you have to
help homeless people from time to time
like that wasn't even a homeless
epidemic I didn't even know how we got
oh we were talking about people asking
you for money on the street to New York
and she made a comment to me she goes
you never know that could be Jesus in
Disguise and then when you die and you
go to heaven he could judge you in that
same outfit on that [__] crushed me
bro how can you turn Jesus down you know
what I'm saying like even if you don't
like [__] God if Jesus is looking for
a quarter you're like you know what even
though I'm Jewish I'm gonna throw him
one just in case I need him later on you
know what I'm saying even if you're
Chinese you're like I gotta help Jesus I
got to throw him a dollar you know
something I Gotta Give Jesus something a
lie to something a crack pipe I just
can't let him be because then he's gonna
come back to me later so you know as
dumb as I am I'm getting my steak on a
stick and she comes over
and everybody was looking at her like
she had three [__] heads
I could be honestly I didn't you know
I'm a little old I just look to the like
Jesus Christ look what's so sad he's
doing
I hate my [__] steak and on the stick
the guy kind of yelled at one of the
guys that
told to get away from the cart because
she was out stinking the cart
and finally
as I turned to the car I had like seven
dollars and eighty cents in my pocket
from the change because I came to guy at
20 and I just gave her what I had you
know and then I went in the car and I
had like another [__] 20 bucks and I
came out and I gave it to him like you
know what
have a great [__] day you know clean
yourself up a little bit get and but
most importantly get something to eat
she was talking to two other homeless
people that were there eating you know
that kind of [__] always wears me out
but my niece had been calling me for the
couple weeks before that saying hey
Uncle Joey when are you gonna come up
and sign my book I like my niece I like
my niece a lot this the runny family I
love him a lot especially these two
girls because their dad was one of the
first
[__] people that told me that I was
dangerous it was after I booked Cold
Case and I was here visiting I was
working some Club in Jersey some [__]
shitty club and he called me up no I
called them to talk to my sister and the
husband said to me Joey I just watched
you on Coke case he goes I don't give a
[__] what anybody tells you you're
pretty good at this [__] and you know
like I told you that my friends always
are the first people to put me down like
don't quit your day job and all that
type of [__] on the way back from the
shows he was one of those guys so for
him to say that to me like threw me a
[__] you know he's like you're gonna
do well with this
keep doing it you know whatever the [__]
so
I always think about them and I call
them a lot and when I lived in L.A my
nieces would come out and we'd go out to
dinner now my older niece is pregnant
and Alyssa's just a [__] Savage so
I went up to take a pic you know just to
see him they were working the projects
and I could have gone to there was like
80 000 different voting places I could
have gone to you know and try to be a
big shot I [__] pulled up with my
little Subaru on the projects you know
and I saw some of the people I hung out
with I saw some of the places I had done
drugs on as a child there's a basketball
court there and I remember playing
basketball there specifically
in 1981 and playing with these group of
kids and in between games they would
snort glue out of a [__] bag and I'm
like wow I'm to a different level trust
me I was a junkie too but I wasn't
[__] snorting glue and what happened
was the kid had pills in his sock like
an aluminum foil so they wouldn't melt
or something and when we were playing
the pillows fell out and somebody picked
them up and he's like threatening
everybody if I don't get my pills so he
got so worked up he got a bag of glue
and while he's yelling at us he's like
if I don't get my [__] pill back I'm
gonna kill one of these and we're
[__] die in a [__] laughter but
that's the first memory
oh my God I don't know what he was
[__] having
but I was like this is this is Classic
this is what comes back to your memory
and I [__] got out and I drank some
water and there was some guys that were
working the polls now I'm not political
guys by no means am I political or do I
have any political aspirations I [__]
hate it as a matter of fact and I hate
how people have reacted to politics the
last seven years everybody's [__] a
political science [__] major now and
everybody don't know dick about Dick
including me so I'm sitting there with
my knees for talking you know bro it was
not it was a beautiful day in Jersey on
Tuesday had to hit like 82 [__]
degrees it was just nice to be outside
you know I had to get back here to take
Mercy to kickboxing or she's got [__]
softball practice or whatever so after a
while I gotta get out of here I took
pictures of some people who were there
and I knew their parents or I knew them
in some shape or form and then they came
over to me with a with a banner you know
and I go let's take a picture what the
now this political system guys since
I've been gone is when they grew
steaming momentum and they're a great
political system but I'm not closer then
I'm not closer than how I was with the
uh earlier regimes who were deemed to be
criminals and whatnot but I did I was
too stupid to know I was just a kid and
they would always keep my basketball
court clean in my world that was good
enough for me
so I never really you know I knew mayor
Sacco from Lincoln School growing up
great guy while we were growing up but I
don't really Pascal baneri I know them
from growing up blah blah blah but I
didn't really get involved in it or
anything you know good for them you know
I'm really happy that they're doing what
they're doing so before they left now I
know listen I'm not popular with them
and I'm not popular up there and that's
okay I I made my bed and I live in a
daily [__] basis but at the same time
I go [__] it let me take a picture with
uh with the banner with my niece I
figure people look at it as a joke holy
[__]
this is why a lot of people need lives
and I say this and it's not the best or
confident thing to say or the most woke
thing to say but it's about time when
people start getting lies back the
pandemic's been over three [__] years
it's okay to get out of the basement and
it's okay to get the [__] off your
computer it really is it's okay
because if you you know you really want
entertainment I tell people all the time
if you got a half hour to kill and you
really want to see the State of the
Union never mind what a president tells
you or there's a State of Union Address
no I'm gonna tell you a real [__]
State of the Union what you do is
[__] wait till Rogan post
and look at one of his posts
just read the comments besides all the
fake [__] yeah it's it's
uh
it's very sad when you read the comments
they're still talking about DMT
they're still talking about
everything no no no no but listen if I'm
looking at episode 108 and I know it was
shot in 2012 and it's 2023.
they didn't
it is I didn't know you
know you was right does it really matter
you know what's taller than him the
stack of hundred dollar bills that he
has so while you think you're making a
phone
he's so short
when you're making that comment know
that he's got two stacks of money taller
than him you know you read these
comments and you're like that's what I
do sometimes if I'm a doctor's office or
a dentist office and I'm bored and I
don't want to watch [__] the wheel
the time is right whatever The Wheel of
Fortune whatever the [__] they're doing
on there yeah I just go on could you go
on Rogan's Instagram
and read the comments and don't please
read the comments when he cooks
something
today was the food post oh my God where
was the tattoo of him a man is cooking
on a [__] ten thousand dollar Grill
okay he's if you know anything about him
he's cooking elk or whatever the [__]
he's cooking that he shot 10 minutes ago
or somebody just gave to him
and you're talking about a rinky dink
restaurant in Kentucky you got to come
to this shut the [__] up and now for a
word from our sponsors the battle for
the NBA titles in full swing get on it
all with playoff action with DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
part of the NBA new customers listen
make a five dollar bet and score 150 and
bonus bets instantly plus everyone could
score a no sweat same game ball way are
you kidding me or what every single day
during the NBA Playoffs which means
today [__] just fire up the
DraftKings Sportsbook app in and place
the same game Paul a on any NBA team
Gabe it's that easy if your bet losers
you still get a bonus bet and the amount
of your initial bet up to ten dollars
you got nothing to lose and everything
to win DraftKings is sports book is fun
an easy way to get it on the action
download the app now and sign up with
code Joey
j-o-e-y new customers can make a five
dollar bet and score 150 in bonus bets
instantly only a DraftKings sports book
with code Joey Gavin problem called
1-800 Gambler if everything's beautiful
keep that party going download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app and let's make
some [__] gears during the NBA
Playoffs because that's it after the NBA
playoffs and the NHL playoffs you're
just playing [__] baseball and you
got nothing to do but scratch your ass
till [__] August 15th so get it on
the NBA playoff now use code Joey all
right we're back [__]
[Laughter]
I was never really a [__] mushroom
guy
let's get something straight I was
always I grew up in Jersey guys you know
I do I did masculine I did acid
I did uh you know [__] all the
variable [__] hallucinogenics but
there was no mushrooms in Jersey they
can't grow here in Jersey
I never really experienced mushrooms
till 19 1983
it was it was uh Fourth of July weekend
1983 my roommate went away and left me I
don't know a bag of mushrooms I ate half
of them and I remember sitting on a
bridge in Snowmass Village and just
tripping my balls off sitting on the
bridge looking at the water the fish
jumping out of the [__] water
and uh
I got sick later on I got a diarrhea and
my stomach got really bad so that was my
first experience with him would I do
them again they weren't that bad The
Taste wasn't so bad and then I went down
to Tempe Arizona with my buddy and I
smoked some mushrooms and they went to
bed they weren't too [__] bad you
know
uh we smoked them in like a big [__]
Indian pipe like it was a peace pipe in
fact I was smoking with some Indians
that's when you know you're [__]
right there when the mother next to
you's got a [__] feather you know
what I'm saying so
so uh
I never again I didn't know much about
it I moved back to Colorado
and uh within about a year I bumped into
a mushroom connection and I would eat
them from time to time but again
it was always a stomach issue and I
remember one night specifically
you know having diarrhea in my Snowmass
house to when I house to that
and tripping at the same time and
holding on to my knees because I thought
the plane was gonna crash like when the
plane goes down like uh hands between
your knees chest and knee whatever the
[__] it you know and I kept I'll never
forget this guys I I was tripping and I
thought I had locked myself in the
bathroom door and it became like a jet
like I didn't know you know like when
people like oh my God you're supposed to
eat one gram listen I'm a [__]
gorilla I just took a handful of them
they were brittle and dry and I just
drank a bunch of [__] water with them
so
you know that night hit me a little
worse than it should have hit me I was
holding on to my knees and then I
remember one point that the toilet
flooded because I couldn't stop wiping
my ass with the paper I sat there for
like an hour and a half guys wiping
wiping wiping nothing was coming out but
the mushrooms were telling me you know
lava was coming out of my ass like a
[__] uh like those things in Hawaii
and the toilet flooded and the water
popped out of the toilet and I remember
sitting on the tub seeing an inch of
water here this is some [__]
mushrooms guys
and the next thing you know I'm looking
at the toilet paper I'm together myself
first I thought I was going to get
electrocuted
because it was floating and they were
like again
guys you know I'm half [__] you
should never give a [__] mushrooms at
that age
and then I kept looking at the paper the
toilet paper kept going
in the middle of all this I'm going how
many trees
the day cut down for me to just to wipe
my ass now you know I'm not an
environmentalist but at that point I
became an environmentalist on the
[__] mushrooms I think they got some
outdoor juice in them or whatever and
after that yeah after that guys after
that experience that night with the
bathroom flooding and the trees and the
[__] me thinking I was going to crash
the plane there was no reason to do it
it hit me a little too hard and I'll
never forget I had another experience
maybe three weeks after that
where I went to a trailer my friend had
a trailer and a mobile home and a lot of
people weren't sleeping a lot of people
were sleeping in his house it was before
a wedding
and he goes Joey if you want you could
sleep out that I'm like this
[__] just saved my life because
I thought I would have to go back to his
house with people in it and I would have
to do Coke in the bathroom all night
while his in-laws and his grandmother
everybody wearing the house now he put
me on the trailer I could watch TV out
there put my feet up and I can [__]
[__] and go to the bathroom all night
and nobody will know what I'm doing I
could be up all [__] night
now went to this guy's house
at the time and
and he he was a coke dealer he had just
gotten out of doing time Mikey his wife
sold Coke to a cop and he took the fall
and he was a Mexican dude he gave me
this coke and again you know when you
don't listen to people
I was always one of those people he's
like uh Joey I don't know what they put
in this but this [__]
[__] strong and I'm like yeah okay
you know and I didn't store it in town I
waited till I got up to his house in the
mountains and I mingled with his family
and I [__] went out to the goddamn uh
I went out to the goddamn RV wherever it
was and at one point then I started
smoking Coke and guys it was like 12
o'clock I'm drinking Coors Light after
Coors Light
I looked at the garbage there must have
been 30 upside down Coors Light
that's when I could snort coke and drink
I was probably 30 31 years old
it's four in the morning that garbage
can is [__] filled to the brim with
Coors Light
and all of a sudden I look after her
into the Horizon you know it was like
the moon was the light you're outside
it's a it's the mountains and the way
the moon was hitting the [__] thing I
started hallucinating
from the speed in the coke
some they had put in the coke was making
me hallucinate and I kept seeing guys
with ropes like Commandos swing down
with their handles and point machine
guns at me and then fall into the cloud
into the puff of snow and I'm like I
can't deal with this first I had the
mushroom incident because I clearly
remember going I think it's time to stop
doing [__] drugs because I just saw I
almost crashed a plane in the bathroom
when I did the [__] mushrooms and I
almost and I just saw [__] you know
Commandos Arnold Schwarzenegger was
coming down the tree with a bunch of
other and they all had white suits on
and white russian wool hats I'm like oh
my God I'm losing it I'm losing it and
I'll never forget making a double note
going I got to give drugs a break but if
you knew anything about me I was back at
it four nights later so
but uh over the years you know I've
eaten them some guy gave me a pound of
them and I had them in the office for a
few weeks Lee ate them and got sick you
know we we if you know they were never
my
big thing uh a couple years ago people
started talking about the therapeutic
values of mushrooms and micro dosing and
what else again I don't even know where
to start you know I was going through my
own [__] nightmare so I I was
thinking
that maybe if I get my hands on some
mushrooms this [__] would work out for
me you know
so I was like okay maybe I'll just get
some mushrooms but I didn't know where
to start and then
about eight months ago a friend of mine
came over and he goes I want you to try
this
and he gave me some uh sillies
mushroom gummies and they were okay you
know they
they did the trick I guess you know and
they didn't do anything to me like
people described I have a hard time
breathing on them like when I eat
mushrooms and I go for a long walk I'm
choking on my breath you know like it's
hard to breathe even though on it uses
those other mushrooms uh to help you
breathe I forget what the
so I'm like you know I don't know if I
should eat these things
fast forward to this week silly sent me
some
chocolate bars
uh they wanted me to try that doing a
chocolate bar they got a Tiramisu and
they got a dark chocolate you know
tiramisu for the Italians in my
neighborhood and I went and they have
other flavors but I wanted to try the
dark chocolate
and uh yeah it's set to eat four pieces
so I had been eating four pieces two
nights in a row and nothing had really
happened I didn't even get clarity I'm
like I don't know if this truck hits
different the next night I showed up
with eight pieces
and my daughter have a softball game
and guys I haven't been in touch with
God in a long [__] time okay
every time you get high you see the
devil not this night
I was right there with God I was on the
softball field
the sky couldn't have been any Bluer
the sun was gone already kind of sort of
but there were no clouds in the sky no
uh yeah there was no clouds the sky was
just blue
and I was watching the picture and my
daughter and all the girls on the field
and the blue from the sky
was like hummings
and it was just feeling there and I
remember just going oh [__] I've entered
the [__] pterodome
and uh I was as happy as I've been since
my mother gave me birth like I was to
that point like I'm like the only thing
that can make me happy and this is me
being naked and my mother holding me
with two hands and shaking me like
that's how warm I felt and it didn't
last for a long time it just felt like
that's like 13 minutes then I went back
into my buzz and I enjoyed watching the
[__] games and you know what
my Wednesday was great and my Thursday
was great so last night I ate eight more
[__] pieces no like two night Friday
night I had eight more pieces and I had
some ABX Edibles that night to balance
them out yeah like eight ABX Edibles I
ate like 1600 milligrams it was Friday
baby it's Miller time [__] you know
it's Miller time we had a great week Law
and Order we went audio [__] the book
went on the charts we got to celebrate
I'm not what are you I'm 60 what do you
want me to do go on hang out with chicks
and jump up and down they don't want to
see me so I did the next best thing I
got high and I went to my daughter's
softball game what do you want from me
that's as good as it gets in my [__]
world right now you know and I felt bad
this week Theo was in town
I really want to go up there and it was
really Wednesday night when I did those
mushrooms at the softball game because
that was the night that the game was
supposed to yeah I told you I got we got
a 5 30 game I should be out of there by
seven it was a 6 15 game I didn't get
out there till [__] eight something
and then with the parents are talking
[__] the mushrooms had me going and then
to make it [__] even worse I dropped
my daughter home
and it said to take the 18 North to get
into something
and as soon as I got the 18 no other
truck
[__] skid I mean three miles from me
I saw this smoke and I had already
passed the exit
so now I got stuck there for an hour and
10 minutes until the cops came and
pulled the truck and had to go and
instead of pulling the right lane they
started from the left lane so I was in
the right lane stuck for [__] an hour
and 10 minutes thank God I had gasoline
and thank God I had a [__] uh one of
those no I didn't have no gummies I had
the uh I had a joint to tame down the
mushroom I had one of those little
joints with the [__] thing and
that was enough for me my friend so that
was my [__] uh savior but I felt you
know listen guys
I'm a firm believer in energy and follow
come on man
I'm [__] I get all the way home I
drop my wife and daughter off I get to
get back in the car
the thing takes me away I've never been
before because usually just doesn't
either pick up the turnpike
and also there's a truck accident
I drive on the 18 every [__] day for
one reason another
and all of a sudden I see a [__]
truck accident
and nobody got hurt or nothing like that
it's just something happened with the
tires I don't know I didn't ask the
[__] cops like that I just wanted to
get the [__] out of there
but it's funny like I always tell people
some nights man you just let it go
something didn't want you to go there
something or something I work off
energies a lot some nights listen they
don't want you to go there do I met my
friends invited me to dinner I knew
where I was walking into I was going to
cause a problem because I didn't want to
see one of my friends there the friend
that I didn't want to see never shows up
to those dinners okay and I know he
doesn't want to see me
but the other night Thursday night I go
you know what
it's time for me to go up there and meet
with these guys they always invite me to
dinner
so what
if I have uh a problem one of the guys
he's not gonna show up anyway
I got home from kickboxing my daughter's
like that let's go eat tonight I'm like
God damn it usually on Thursdays they
just want to go upstairs and watch
something that comes on TV and they
and then make something to eat something
simple not that night they wanted to go
so now I ended up going with them to get
sushi at like 6 15. I didn't get out of
there until like 7 30. by the time I got
up north it's 8 30 I'm like you know
what something didn't want me to go up
there next [__] day I go on Facebook
he was there they took a picture and he
was there so
sometimes I just left I let the timing I
don't push things sometimes you know if
you're not supposed to be there you get
pissed for two minutes then you go wow I
went home got high and had a Carvel
shake and it was better any time I would
have had with them so it's just weird
how life Works itself out and that's it
[__] it's Monday the 15th we're
at the halfway mark
and it's going to be another [__]
great week everything is coming into
play and uh I'm feeling better and
everything is working out I don't know
what podcast I'm doing this week I think
I got to get back on sickler give him
some love and uh
that sick [__] suck is when I get the
book signings in I'll keep you posted
but what I think I'm gonna do is I'm
waiting until I do that TV thing for the
24th and then I should have dates
because it'll be a lot easier to
announce them on that news 12. so they
won't I probably won't get the dates
till about the [__] 24th of May but I
really want to see you guys I really
want to sign your book I don't want to
do any theaters or any comedy clubs I
don't want to do that and then should
like charge you again for the book just
come to borders I don't care if you
bought the book of Barnes and Nobles put
it under your [__] person come in and
sign and we'll get a giggle and you can
[__] leave and jump up and down
beside that I love you [__]
with all my heart
stay black
have a great week and I'll be in touch
if you need me for anything go to my
patreon it's a fin to get in and that's
it [__] I love you with all my
heart have a great week and I'll see you
next week Tip Top [__] Magoo
and now for a word for my goddamn
sponsors all right thank you for
listening to the Joint today the new and
uh audio joint Let's Talk About Sex it's
Monday boys remember when you could be
able to go all night long pull hair jump
up and down now you throw a stab and
your back hurts for a week you need to
get your hands on some blue shoe it's
erectile dysfunction medicines medicine
that ship straight to your door it's got
the same ingredients as Viagra Cialis
and Levitra but in chewable tablets at a
fraction of the cost listen I love this
stuff I have it in my drawer every once
in a while while I'm in the mood you
know I'm an old man I need a little
extra something you just eat one [__]
pill and you're ready to go within
minutes and it's easy and entirely
online no trips to the doctors no
awkward conversations and everything is
shipped in a discreet package just sign
up at bluetooth.com meet with one of the
licensed medical providers and once you
get approved you'll get your
prescription within days Bluetooth wants
to help you have better sex discover
your options at bluetooth.com
do it and do it plus your uncle Joy has
got a special deal for my listeners try
Bluetooth for free that's right free
when you use promo code Joey at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code Joey to receive
your first month free